good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast
and happy Friday day Friday got to get
down on
Friday hope everybody's looking forward
to the weekend weekend weekend what a
beautiful rendition hey lard how you
doing you're giving us a little bit of
sticky shoes are you sick or are you
tired I woke up just not feeling like
100% so I'm working from home that's why
today's episode W feeling
100% don't let forget thank you for
reminding me end know that we are not
enough people talk about my song 100%
not at all it's so good it's serious I
haven't thought about 100% in so long I
think about toast all the time you know
every anytime I need like a song in the
background for an Instagram that we have
the rights to like right you know it's
always toast but it's never 100% I'm
actually really glad you brought that up
because I definitely feel like everybody
sat on my um follow-up hit single called
100% it's available to stream on Spotify
I have two songs in case you're new here
one is kind of like our it's Anthem
Matic it's like the song of the toast
it's called toast and it's amazing and
it was actually really hard to you know
follow that up and I Rose to the
occasion I [__] did 100% is so good
and I feel like people sleep on it I
feel like people sleep on it too and I
actually it's really one of those songs
it's grown on me like when you first
sent me the sample I was like the demo
the demo I was like I just I didn't see
the vision honestly I I thought it was
kind of like a flop but in many ways
since it's been released like in many
ways it's better than toast so what
you're saying is that I'm not
appreciated in my own time no and that
you're not a one hit wonder thank you
that's me and Olivia Rodrigo
exactly um so today's episode is going
to be fun flirty and fresh done from
home thank you everyone for your
patience but it wouldn't be a toast
episode if I didn't have the biggest
news of the day really what's the news
the biggest news of the day oh does you
guys this is real I can confirm this is
news over a year in the making okay I
want to say two years I want to say
three what's the news
lard
lard is on
La lard will be seeing the snow before
Christmas because lard
has found a new apartment that's right
she said she would and she did and
everyone including her own [__]
sister was a doubter
nonbeliever because once were her
dreamers yeah no one talks about that
lar enough it's like yeah we started
doubting you but we once dreamed we were
once Reon but then you know we moved on
with our lives well I didn't and what's
so crazy is like I was prepared to to
come on this podcast in the following
weeks and tell everyone I was staying in
my apartment this apartment that I the
the last apartment that I saw that I
ended up taking was like this last ditch
effort I was even I was actually just
going to cancel the appointment I'm like
there's no way it's even going to work
nothing has worked for me it's below my
budget I was like there's just no way
and I was Ben was like let's just go
let's just go and we walked in and we
knew it we knew it so I guess the
message and the lesson here is to never
give up on your dreams no and when you
know you know and trust your gut oh I
had my application wire money I had
literally done everything hour serious
that's what I meant like you weren't
serious before with like oh 3 weeks
later I'll give an offer the tap of what
they're asking you don't want it you
never know you never know you wanted
this and you made it happen and I'm
literally moving in two weeks like it's
so imminent I'm going to La we have your
book launch and then right after that
I'm moving so I might need to take a day
off of work I got to talk to H jar um
I'm so excited like me and Ben have not
stopped talking about it I have a huge
kitchen like like a real kitchen like a
home kitchen like my ass I'm learning to
cook that's my next thing like I'm
getting cookbooks and [__] like it's a k
oh my God that's added to the list
Jackie it's a kitchen that deserves to
be cooked in my kitchen now deserves
nothing no I agree your kitchen right
now is like a very much like a City
Kitchen Carri Brad shoes in the oven
it's like a galley it's small like
there's no counter space I have an
island yeah you're going to having to
cook guess what else I have what unheard
of in New York City
balcony well I do have that but that's
not what I was referring to a garbage
disposal in your unit uhhuh no no no
garbage disposal the thing in the sink
oh no I had one at my last apartment no
you didn't yeah I did no you didn't no I
no Jackie nobody has one you didn't have
one okay yeah yeah no no I didn't have
one yeah no like I'm special and
different like I I have one and guess
guess what else I have which was like
the whole impetus for leaving this
apartment I have views NorthEast
Southwest I can see it all from every
room I'm I'm really humbled and I wanted
to thank everyone for joining me on this
journey like I know how torturous it
was but my new home like I have a
bedroom like you come to town Jackie
stay with me like we will true we will
all reap the benefits of my new home so
yes I put you through torture but like
it's for you
oh my god I didn't even think about that
as you were going through this journey
like if I come with my family as I do
yeah two kids husband maybe stri sand
would you let us all stay with you of
course if you would all stay in one
bedroom I only have it's only two
bedrooms yeah know it would be like me
Harry Charlie in one bedroom and then
we'd have to make no sorry me Zach
Charlie in one bedroom and then we'd
have to make like Harry a little setup
we' figure it out by the way if you
would stay I would absolutely love I
would stay Bruno Theo in my room oh my
God this sh's Brethren and so me and Ben
have never had like an extra bedroom
before so we're kind of like arguing
about what to do with it like for me
it's a guest room like it needs a
king-sized bed a TV and a desk so that
like during you know non-v visiting
hours someone can use it as an office
right and Ben's like so hellbent on the
idea of a Murphy bed oh goodness and
like I don't know how to tell him like
that's not happening why what does he
want to use the room for he just wants
like of course if somebody's coming to
stay we have a bed a Murphy bed but like
who knows like we could use all the
space for something else like he doesn't
even have an idea he just like wants to
save the space that's how it becomes a
room full of crap agreed like I want it
to be like a really Chic like so many of
the furniture in my current bedroom is
not going to work in my new bedroom but
I have it for the guest room like I
already I already have everything I need
yeah that's how it goes that's like my
guest room in my house is full of
furniture from New York oh and you know
what else I
have this is actually unheard of what a
fireplace wow electric so I don't smell
up the whole place that's good just like
on off on off like when I walked in I
was like oh this is the type of home I
can cultivate A vibe in I can get a
chili on light the fire oh living room
my living room uh lighting is on a
dimmer I love a dimmer I love a dimmer
perfect for setting and cultivating A
vibe well you're just in time cuz it's
Vibe season Jackie I'm making it by the
skin of my teeth and are you going to
have to get new furniture like are you
going to get work with a designer or so
I'm going to move take everything I own
with me and I'll reevaluate yeah I'm not
I'm not going to go and measure like
I'll bring all my [__] and I'll figure
it out yeah and then you'll see what you
need yeah but I think I'll have to
probably sell some of my stuff a lot of
my furniture here is oversized this new
apartment is like it's big but it's not
like big enough for all of my furniture
so um I'm going to have to get some new
stuff I'm going to have to sell some
stuff like okay if I'm a listener I'm
asking how is your next apartment like
not big enough for your furniture but
your current apartment is a good
question so I live in a one-bedroom
right now and it's just like this
oversized one bedroom it's a pre-war
building which what basically what that
means is that it's bigger like all the
new buildings that are built in the last
20 years they're that's where like New
York gets The Stereotype for tiny
Apartments like it's it's inhumane what
they do so if you find a building that's
pre-war this is like somebody lived in
this apartment 50 years ago and like it
was normal size for like normal people
that's not what I think of what I think
of pre-war I didn't know that's what it
meant that's what it ConEd what do you
think of I just think it's like made
with quality materials it doesn't like
go up with like sheet rock that too by
the way like that people are always like
how do your neighbors not complain about
your singing it's cuz oh cuz I have real
wols cuz they're pre-war like that to me
is where pre-war comes in yeah but it's
also about the sizing and and like the
proportions and the ceiling height I
didn't know that but actually is crazy
to me because I feel like 50 years ago
people were smaller than they are today
and they were but their Apartments were
not like when you look at Miss masel
like that's pre-war got it okay good to
know so I live in a really big one
bedroom so I have a big living room by
wait which war that's why I said 50
years ago I'm not entirely sure um also
at this point 50 years ago like was the
80s no I know I think it's pre-war is
like the 20s yeah so it's pre World War
II I don't [__] know um so I live in
a one bedroom s off in the comments
which war which yeah what the [__] does
pre-war mean yeah so I live in a one
bedroom but it's just really oversized
so I have like a huge couch a huge
dining table rugs everywhere my bedroom
is enormous um so I have really big
furniture to fill the space of a
one-bedroom now my next apartment is
more square feet but it's also two
bedrooms and two full baths and I have
like a laundry room so there's more
square footage cuz there's more things
but it's not as over like the dining
room isn't the biggest thing you've ever
seen whereas my dining room right now
like I have so much Furniture in it
because there was just nothing like
there was so much space yeah so if that
makes sense yeah makes sense to me I'm
so excited like it's all I think about I
like this is just the best day of my
life like thank God I've been waiting to
move for so long and you know what good
another lesson good things come to those
who wait I didn't rush she did not I did
not well I'm really excited for when
you're in there and I'll come see you
cuz I might be coming in November so
maybe I'd stay with you
100% wow I just need to get a new bed
frame for your for your room thuma thuma
yeah and I also I'm going to hit up some
of our toe sponsors now that I'm like
moving I need a mattress
mattressfirm.com mhm I need just like a
ton of stuff I need new uh bowling
Branch like it's going to be it's going
to be a a toast approved apartment yeah
maybe you get a new set of car ways to
Chris in the new kitchen
100% yeah I see big things for I need it
all oh and of course before you move in
you've got to wipe the place down with
Branch Basics
100% so that's my major life update
pretty much the only thing going on in
my life except for the fact that I'm
coming to see you in two days because my
book is launching on Tuesday you guys
we're getting so close to Pub day are
you sure it's not Monday I'm positive oh
my God this whole time I thought it was
Monday no Monday is a Federal holiday oh
right yes it is
Columbus indigenous people and the toast
is honoring as we do all federal
holidays and we will not be releasing an
episode so don't be looking for us on
Monday but come looking for us on
Tuesday because it's a big day so don't
like look for us where you normally find
us on Monday but you'll be hearing from
me a lot because it's the day before Pub
day Tuesday is Pub day next week is Pub
week so what you're trying to say is
prepare to be sick of me me if you're
not already I'm so excited for Pub week
you guys I'm so excited for campers to
get their hands on this book for
counselors to read it to them and for
all of you guys to know like what the
[__] I've been talking about also so
much in my life like you know how I
always quote like your special back to
you or just like thing you know your
book whatever like there are so many
phrases from the book that I find myself
saying I hope you like meatballs on top
of spaghetti or anytime I say whoo I say
whoa I'm not going in that lake so true
which is what happens don't spoil it I'm
not going to spoil it but able to speak
freely we did tease earlier in the week
that something kind of monumental
happens at the lake yeah it gets a
little crazy yeah so if you haven't yet
pre-order your copy and get in on the
fun I'm doing a book signing at books
and greetings in New Jersey on Saturday
October 14th at 11:00 a.m. it's going to
be so much fun for the campers for the
counselors bring your kids if you want
or not if you don't and we're going to
have some treats from Once Upon A Farm
they're sponsoring sending pouches for
the campers so cute so cute so you could
fuel up while you're in line we're going
to have a great time and that is the
only event I'll be doing next week I was
planning something else um but I
actually don't have enough books to do
the event because we sold out of the
first printing you know what you know
what we call that
what I don't know I don't know success
yeah so um it won't affect like
individual book orders cu the warehouse
is going to be replenished on Thursday
but I just won't have enough books to do
an event on Friday which is cool a good
problem to have I'll miss you guys I'm
going to do more events when I'm in New
York next and throughout the holiday
season I'm going to do events in Florida
but just for launch week it's the one
event books and greetings Northvale New
Jersey come see Yad girl so exciting
what a big week next week is for
Columbus for the indigenous and for Tako
and the campers and the counselors 100%
yeah so with all that said I feel like
we can dive into the fast five stories
that you need to know to round out the
week and get you ready for the weekend
who am I to stop you you
can't I Can't Stop the Beat that's for
sure you can't no you can't so without
further Ado here are the fast five
stories that you need to know and the
fast five stories that you yes you need
to know are brought to you by Lululemon
it is officially Sweater Weather and
that means we need good leggings and
Lululemon is your One-Stop shop for all
different types of leggings whe whether
you're a casual leggings wear you like
to travel in leggings you are lead a
very active lifestyle they have all
different types of lululemons for
whatever you looking for so here are
some of our favorites the fast and free
leggings those are the ones that are
powered by the new Lux fabric so they
provide a weightless on body sensation
and incredible coverage and it's
designed for those looking for a legging
that gives them a complete freedom from
distractions while running or jogging so
these are really good leggings if you
are an active girlly you are working out
you are running you need that that that
legging to hold you in and keep you free
that's the fast and free legging they
also have the Wonder Trin legging which
are designed with one of Lululemon's
most Innovative Fabrics it's called
everlux the everlux fabric is their
fastest d drying fabric so the Wonder
Trin leggings allow you to work hard and
feel dry so you can effortly transition
from sweat to stet so if you're a big
sweater and you're working out and you
need leggings that are not going to keep
your you know coochie cold you got to
stay dry try the Wonder trained leggings
also even if you're not active you're
just like a sweaty person which I
definitely am Wonder train leggings are
great I just like leggings that keep
dryness in mind but by far my favorite
are the Align leggings I happen to just
love the Align collection from Lululemon
those are powered by the nulu fabric
they're designed for a person who wants
a lightweight low compression yoga
solution that is also versatile enough
for casual wear it gives the wearer a
next to nothing body sensation so it's
great for low intensity workouts or just
for casual wear get into Lululemon
leggings at lululemon.com that's
lemon.com today's episode is also
brought to you by the farmers dog the
farmer's dog in our opinion is the best
option for dogs at all life stages
because it's not kibble it's not canang
goo it is real healthy dog food so
traditional dry and wet dog food options
are super processed they can use much
lower quality ingredients than they
claim to and they are extremely
difficult to portion accurately but the
farmer's dog isn't just fresh healthy
quality fresh higher quality dog food
they also send the food pre- Portion
specifically for your dog based on the
unique nutritional needs of your dog so
it makes it easy to help your dog
maintain their ideal weight which is one
of the biggest indicators of a full
healthy life um the fresh diet has been
found to have all sorts of benefits so
for Theo we switched him a little while
ago one of my biggest complaints was his
breath it just didn't feel normal it
didn't feel healthy and it certainly
wasn't good switching over to the
farmer's dog his breath is so much
better his bowels are more consistent
he's making like you know better sizing
and you know more consistent poops his
coat is super shiny he just has like an
overall spring in his step and I really
I'm so glad I switched to the farmer's
dog it doesn't matter if your dog is
young or old it's always the right time
to begin investing in their health
helping you live a more healthy happy
and full year together with your dog and
so that means more magical moments with
your dog but no act actual magic is
required get 50% off your box of fresh
healthy food at thefarmersdog.com
plus you get free shipping when you go
to thefarmersdog.com toast so go to
thefarmersdog.com toast and you will get
50% off your first box plus free
shipping and a lifetime of joy and
happiness with your strice brethren
which honestly is the best thing I could
possibly offer thank you Claudia you're
welcome our first story let's see what
is sad let's see what I
chose yeah it's making me sad Sophie
Turner leaves day one of Joe Jonas
custody and divorce mediate after 8
hours and then it was also reported that
Joe left 2 hours after that so that he
was there for 10 hours but Sophie and
Joe spent eight hours together on
Wednesday during day one of their 4-day
mediation The Game of Thrones star was
photograph leaving the meeting in New
York alongside her lawyer at 6 p.m.
wearing jeans and white T-shirt and a
green cable knit sweater earlier in the
day she was spotted leaving Taylor
Swift's apartment where she's been
staying with her two daughters the two
uh formerly married Stars arrived
separately and left at different
times this is really sad I also can't
remember a celebrity breakup or divorce
in recent memory where we had so much
information and photos on like the
timeline and and details like it feels
so wrong yeah but it's all it's so
public maybe it's happening so quickly
because like of the way that she had to
sue them for keeping the kids um cuz
usually people get file for divorce
maybe in a few months they'll have their
trial I think these two have their trial
in January but they're trying to do
mediation to figure out a way to
co-parent and exist without going to
court so I hope an 8h hour day means it
was a success I also feel like don't I
feel like most custody arrangements and
forgive me if I'm wrong start with
mediation like everybody tries to
because you hope and you want to think
that you can do it without copious
lawyers and a judge and you can come to
an agreement but I guess you know most
most of the time you can't no and
especially with like the UK of it all
it's so complicated I feel like I don't
want to be negative but I really don't
feel like they can settle this without
going to court yeah I feel like they're
going to wind up spending a lot of time
in New York just because it's like in
between central it's New York and LA
everyone can work from New York yeah I I
also think we have so much information
on the comings and goings of everyone
because they're in New York New York is
just like La you can like go to see your
lawyer and go in the back and nobody can
see you but like New York you pull up in
a cab and you have to walk like it's
just the vibe of the city that makes it
more um like Paparazzi friendly honestly
yes but I feel like in so many ways New
York is where celebrities come to be
anonymous not in this situation but you
know La is more like the paparazzi City
all these restaurants you can't go to
without being snapped but there is
something about the legal proceedings
here that make it just very VIs but yes
celebrities do come to New York to
disappear and that's because people in
New York like the civilians don't give a
[__] yeah even though like don't speak
for me cuz I care yeah I mean everyone
cares they just like to think that they
they like to think that they're the
types that they don't care yeah no we
care yeah we care a hell of a lot so I
hope they're able to mediate it this
whole situation gives me such a pit for
everyone involved I know it's really sad
especially like when you think they're
so far off you know like he wants to
live in America she says we agreed to
live in the UK they have that house in
the UK like they're not even close yeah
and their daughters are like going to be
starting school soon and need to like
they don't want to be going they need to
get settled yeah they can't be like
switching schools in the middle of the
year it's giving Parent Trap yeah yeah
that's what Nick and Elizabeth were up
against yeah what they did like probably
was one of the worst decisions two
parents could have made splitting up not
just siblings twins TNS not enough
people talk about that the neglect the
poor decision two idal strangers and I
get served all these reals of like twins
in utero and like premature twins who
like don't know that they've been born
yet and so the way that they act
thinking that they're still in they're
they're one yeah no and like I'm sorry
but Nick and Elizabeth are no better
than the Elise wise agency no we don't
talk enough about how the parents in
Parent Trap were psychologically
terrorists that was psychological
torture and how the kids turned out to
be so well no wonder they got to camp
and started bullying immediately right
no you so
true they were deeply Disturbed
individuals no wonder they both had to
go to the isolation cabin but like they
were having behavioral issues gee I
wonder why maybe because I was separated
with my twin and not even not even at
Birth I feel like it was like a few
months later so they yeah it like they
had grown to life together yeah they
knew that the other one existed and then
this half of them was just ripped from
them I'm so glad we're having this
conversation cuz it's really it needed
to be sad yeah which is why even though
the camper on the counselor is Parent
Trap coded it kind of like solves that
inherent issue because it's just a
singular camper Jackie you know what
you're doing I'm healing the trauma
you're doing better like you said you
would like I said I would no that's so
true thank you for making the
distinction so just know if you dock
pick up a copy of the camper in the
couns like you're not supporting
psychological terrorism no and there's
no like longl twin who's been ripped
from maybe that's the sequel she comes
next summer British camper oh yeah no
that is French camper and Italian camper
yeah it's me French
camper can I bring my H cigarettes
no
anyways wishing them well wishing them
well our next story someone else who
needs to be wished well it's like a
dramatic headline for like a semi-
dramatic story but once we parse it out
it's like not that drama drama but it's
like the breaking news tab on page six
so they're trying to like make it drama
Drake may be taking a break for music
for maybe a year due to health issues
okay so Drake is taking a Hiatus to take
care of a personal matter he was on
Serious XM sound 42 table for one show
he said I probably won't make music for
a little bit I'm going to be real with
you I need to focus on my health first
and foremost and I'll talk about that
soon enough nothing crazy but just like
you know I want people to be healthy in
life I've been having the craziest
problems for years with my stomach I'm
just saying what it is so so I need to
focus on my health and I need to get
that right and I'm going to do that well
let's we not forget Drake is Jewish and
nobody has more stomach and
gastrointestinal issues than the Jewish
people so he's honoring his Heritage by
Falling victim to what we all experience
and just know that your people are with
you Drake yeah he's got to get his gut
health in order maybe he should try seed
that's what I'm thinking but it's like
on the one hand wow he's having bad
enough stomach issues that he's taking a
break for music for a year like this is
kind of serious on the other hand if
Drake didn't put out music for a year if
any artist doesn't put out music for a
year uh that's fine no one's batting
eyelash you need to take the time right
you need to live you need to write
experience to tour it's a process now I
will say Drake is like obviously like a
very eligible bachelor and now because
he said it like I am envisioning him on
the toilet screaming crying you know
shouting for help um because he said it
like he said I'm having the craziest
stomach so I'm picturing him completely
naked drenched and sweat screaming
crying throwing up you know and I just
almost wish he didn't do that because
now the image in my brain I have of
Drake has been permanently altered yeah
yeah it's hard to say you're having
stomach issues like
without just envisioning that whenever
like I'm like let's say I'm I'm having
some sort of stomach issue like let's
say I'm having diarrhea I will like nine
times out of 10 tell someone if it's
somebody who I like care about how they
see me I'll tell them I threw up instead
of having diarrhea course why is
throwing up so much more
palatable than the other
end because it's not Duty like that's
the thing it's ND it's not Duty yeah
like I'm not the only one who does that
right okay maybe Drake's been throwing
up he would have said it though to throw
us off the
scent yeah and when you say stomach
issues like girls with stomach issues
it's Duty like we know but I feel like
girl when girls with stomach issues are
being like girls with stomach issues
it's
constipation or
IBS what's but what how does IBS
manifest
itself
blowout yikes yeah and I just feel like
this is Jake really showing his male
privilege because a girl would never say
this
no but girls are always talking about
their stomach but like in girl
communities you know you think yeah no
they girls love talking about their
stomachs you know what I I feel like
there was a time where I I maybe like
played into that cuz like that's what
the girls were talking about you just
wanted to like you know get along with
everon yeah I was just trying to make
friends but I actually feel like you say
like Jewish people like have like
stomach issues like I don't relate to
that like I feel I don't want to jinx
myself but I just feel like I'm like
regular dular that's such a privilege
and not you like bragging about it I
don't feel like I'm regular degular like
you don't like the most random things
can set me off is that not from
o uh you're obsessed with me and no it's
been my whole life honestly like for no
for no reason at all issues yeah like
for no reason at all like I'll get the
runs like why that's so weird yeah you
don't get that no
oh not for like no reason at all but
like sometimes like I probably ate
something
wrong okay but like how many times a
year a
year I don't know a year is a long time
let's do how many times a
month
twice one or less one or none we're
splitting hairs here yeah no I'm just
trying to I'm just trying to I just
think you're like in denial that you're
a part of the crow cuz based on the
frequency that you just
spoke 12 maybe I'm just like you know
I'm like I'm a sufferer and I just like
suffer in silence so maybe it's like I'm
not even registering when I'm having
this experience because I'm just like
let's get through it it's over I'm not
thinking about it I'm not like tabul
tabulating that's fair you definitely
are like a suffer in silence whereas
like me I'm in pain everybody's going to
know I have a chronic issue you're going
to text the chat everyone no I'm and I'm
going to make it into like what chronic
illness do I have right right right
right okay well wishing Drake Well I
don't think he needed to share this
because one now we're thinking about it
two if he didn't release music for a
year like nobody would think anything of
it he's not like an artist on the rise
who needs to like keep putting out music
like okay don't don't do anything for
here see I feel like he also just put
out an
album and he also just did like a big
tour so a taking a break would be you
know very common yeah I guess we have to
respect his transparency for sure and
all that travel really can mess up your
stomach ain't that the truth EX I don't
know if like you fly on your own private
jet that has a king bed like I don't
know if you still get the same things
that we get no not the same but like
there's still the cabin pressure still
you're in unfamiliar places maybe eating
new food jet lag no but seriously I feel
like when you travel like Drake does
nothing's unfamiliar like you bring
everything with you no I know I'm just
Drake has problems
too that's true celebrities they're just
like us they get
diarrhea are you ready for our next
story
yeah a little new romantic news baby
with the new Romantics come come along
with me someone who was never on our
list but should have absolutely been on
our list but now would be taking off our
list because they're in a new
relationship is Jay Cutler he has gone
Instagram official with Samantha
Robertson three years after his divorce
from K Christen cavalary he absolutely
should have been on our list absolutely
should have been on our list we could
have had so much fun with him I'm just
thinking of all of the good times we
could have shared unless three years us
yeah we we dropped the ball but it's a
reminder that we should add Kristen to
our
list
yes has she been in any like major
public relationships since her divorce
not really long relationships but she
was dating that comedian Jeff D was that
name yeah yeah there's a rumor that she
went on a date with Morgan Wallen cuz
she was like at his concert wow really
mhm but I don't know if it was just cuz
she was at his concert like I don't know
how much
Credence there is yeah and then of
course like the Southern Charm boys who
knows what happened there yeah yeah yeah
okay anyways Jay Cutler has found love
with Samantha Robertson they have gone
Instagram official they post uh posted a
photo posing on a balcony in front of a
stunning sunset in Montana with Samantha
leaning on Jay resting her arm on his
back and a couple other photos from
their travels Jay Cutler like really
like I feel looks wise also just brand
wise reminds me so much of Aaron Rogers
okay do you feel that I do I do like
they're both just like football players
who are handsome and like had celebrity
relationships maybe that's why I think
they're so similar yeah they're also
like kind probably around the same age
they're also kind of like Renegades in
what they say and do like they don't
give a [__] yeah they just say what's on
their mind yeah I could see there's a
similar energ there's a similar energy
like I could see when Aaron's done with
the NFL like him doing a podcast just
like Jay Cutler does now he does a
podcast I believe so cuz I remember he
did Sophia with an f and then Sophia
went on his and I listened to both
episodes oh you're right and it was were
shipping them so
hard uncut with Jay Cutler sounds like a
podcast about uh circumcision I think
that's the point it's a play on words
and he's Jay cut and he's he also hasn't
released an episode since September
so maybe he's done a year maybe he's out
of the game we also need to keep a list
of podcasts that started that ended I
love that idea because every celebrity
every influencer everyone comes out with
a podcast they do this like big thing
and then you know everyone shoots to
number one they screenshot it but like
what happened a year later are we still
doing our podcast start the list start
the list because I don't know I don't
know if I made this a story but they
canceled em Emily radowski's podcast
yeah yes I saw that too so podcasts that
are over Jay Cutler Jay Cutler and also
they could always come back and they'll
come off our list yeah of course
Mada but Mada I read the story about
hers it's like she still owns her
podcast she could bring it back if she
wants to but like Sony folded it because
I think they said she had too much of an
international audience and and
advertisers wanted domestic listeners
okay so maybe she'll come off the list
also I mean famously Megan and Harry oh
my goodness also Kim Kardashian's like
fake Justice podcast whatever that was
yeah archetypes Kim Spotify I'll call it
wow I don't even know the
name right I'm I'm just looking
online yeah there's this um 13 celebrity
podcast you need to listen to and like
the first three are already cancelled
high low
archetypes that's
funny um so far all of these I believe
are
still and I'm sure there are a bunch
that have like kind of shuttered but
there was no announcement you know if we
went yeah that's how it is like you'll
slowly
yeah oh she's still releasing okay okay
who I didn't know that Sophia Bush had
her own podcast I know that there was
like a a bunch of the girls from One
Tree Hill but she has her own called
work in progress but they literally put
out an episode yesterday so cool I
didn't know aelle had a podcast yeah yes
you did yes you did on
Spotify but I thought I thought it was
her and her husband no he has a podcast
with Bruce Springsteen I think what yeah
and I think it's all on Spotify yeah
yeah no I remember that they did a deal
with Spotify okay so sorry she that she
was on the
list oh Ashley Graham's podcast what
happened to that remember Kim went on it
yeah yeah let me let me look it up 20 oh
it's done 2020 put her on the
list this is funny it is cuz like I just
I keep going of these articles like 25
celebrity podcasts you need to listen to
for inspiration and let's see if any of
them are
still oh smartless yeah we know that
one's still
up that one's still up I heard smartless
is ending no
stop that would be like the best day of
my life I'm totally kidding by the way I
have a lot of respect for them oh my God
if of course it's all in good fun it's I
don't think anybody thinks that it's not
in good fun also like we are completely
punching up like yeah like they don't
care about us I didn't know Ricky Lake
had a podcast me neither does she let's
search everyone has a podcast
Claudia she hasn't released an episode
since July 2023 but she could be on
break yeah she could be on break I won't
add her to the list
yet uh Anderson Cooper
that doesn't sound right maybe his show
then becomes a podcast nope November
20122 put him on the
list
Oprah I feel like Oprah wouldn't quit a
podcast like if she's doing no and I
feel like if it was like actually Oprah
talking like it would be the biggest
podcast in the world it's probably like
some affiliate yeah because
it stopped on 2018 like that's this list
I'm looking at is is old does Anna
Ferris still do her podcast I think so
her podcast like she's a podcaster it
was so big at one time
yeah her podcast yep she had Glenn and
Doyle on two days ago Glenn and Doyle
that's when you know you're podcasting
by the way that's how you know you're
podcasting Ellen
Pompeo this is the most fun game I've
ever played let me know if you're
getting annoyed with me yet I'm not but
we're obsessed with podcasting Pompeo by
hasn't released an episode in a year
we're just obsessed with podcasting
Claudia oh you know who we have to add
to the list who Margot ashre best of
both you know who we have to add to the
list Olivia ashre maternity
live put them on the list the ashre
sisters yeah the sisters ashre couldn't
crack
it but Margo still does
redheads true what does Olivia have to
say for herself I just have to say about
the redheads our episode hit number 11
in the
Arts so you're a woman in the Arts oh we
are women in the Arts and the episode is
so good we read fourth wi talking about
fourth wi and you guys need to become a
redhead it's never too late to become a
redhead ever I'm like downloading it so
that when like I don't want to forget
cuz I'm going to read the book and then
I want to listen to the episode so I
have to read my book club book first I
really need to start what's your book
club book again the measure we read that
for the redheads oh I'll listen to the
redheads episode as well yeah I'm so
curious to hear your thoughts on it it
was one of my best books of the year and
it's probably my first book club
recommendation like if you are in a book
club read the measure it's so good for
chitchatting oh good because we had like
a big meeting with the book club because
we've now all there's seven people in
the book club we've been doing it for
seven months so now we're starting again
and we're like listen we all need to do
better with the selects like everyone's
trying too hard like trying to be
different like we need to pop our
[__] this year and so Rachel came out
strong with the measure it's really hard
to do a book club and pick books that
you have not read like if I did a book
club like you know Oprah and Reese they
read hundreds of books and then they
pick the best one and they recommend it
and you know that it's good with red
it's actually like it's not even a book
club because that's it's like it's a
recommendation yeah with redheads like
we're all taking shots in the dark and
most of them are strong there's a few
exceptional ones and there's a couple
misses which also makes it fun but it
does make it difficult yes
any other celebrity podcasts come to
mind I'm obsessed with this no but we'll
we'll keep our list running yeah oh drop
a comment like who's the celebrity
podcast that you listen to and they just
stopped doing it yeah totally anyway so
back to Jay Cutler his podcast is over I
thinkon Rogers could do a podcast cuz
Aaron Rogers goes on the Pat McAfee show
now like every day week making headlines
and he's just like sitting back crack
he's cracking on in the love Island
terms and I think he could do that on a
podcast whenever chooses yeah I think so
too even though I think he's probably
going to take actually no I don't think
he would take a broadcasting deal cuz he
likes to be say to say whatever whatever
the [__] he wants yeah no that's the
thing I feel like he would be actually a
great podcaster because he kind of runs
his mouth and there are other people who
like to talk but they you know
everything they say is very like
approved they do the talking points
perfect for TV they hit the points and
those people should be on TV and that's
what TV wants but Aaron no he's got a
mouth for podcasting so true cuz like
did he go on Joe
Rogan that's an amazing question I know
they were like I know they're friendly
and there was a time where they were
very um oh yes he was August
2022 yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so I think
he's got what it takes before we move on
May I say something you may because our
next two stories actually need to be
coupled together so this would be the
perfect time okay so that's why I was
going to do it so no but I just like
want to tell you know why you could say
it thank you so much Jackie these next
two stories that are coupled together
are brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace is the all-in-one website
platform for entrepreneurs to stand out
and succeed online whether you're just
starting out or managing a growing brand
Squarespace makes it easy to create a
beautiful website engage with your
audience and sell anything from products
to content all in one place all on your
own terms so whether you need a website
made for your business a side hustle you
want to start what you do for work
there's a million reasons and you know
in this state and age you got to have a
fire website no one's going to take you
seriously without it but it's kind of
like a daunting task to build a whole
website I think a lot of people study
for many years on how to do that and if
you wanted to pay a company to do that
it would cost you a lot of money that's
where Squarespace comes in they can get
your website up and running for whatever
it is that you possibly need it for so
quickly and it will look so professional
so whether you're selling custom merch
you want to sell your products in an
online store you want to even sell in
person they have a point of sale where
you can um sell in person by connecting
a square reader to the Squarespace app
you can keep your orders your inventory
your custom data you can keep it all in
sync with your online store whether you
want to you know create a portfolio
you're a videographer or a photographer
and you want to have like a video
collection or a photo collection
whatever you're using your website for
there is a template on Squarespace that
will make it so easy to navigate it'll
look so well done and it'll all be done
so easily with Squarespace and you and
there's really no better reason than to
go with Squarespace so if you want to
head to squarespace.com you can get a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com toast and
you'll get 10% off your first purchase
of a website or a domain that's
squarespace.com toast for 10% off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
thank you lard you're welcome L Jax our
next story some of our favorite subject
matters Costco chili debate okay
Costco's chili stirs up debate on Tik
Tok regarding one controversial
ingredient so as you guys know it's
chili season Costco apparently has chili
because of course they do they have
everything I'm sure their chili is
delicious some Tik tokers were posting
like it's chili season back at Costco
showing the goods but now there's a
debate raging about whether or not beans
belong in
chili beans so Costco's chili the
Kirkland Signature chili is made up of
Usual Suspects beef onions cheese wide
range of spices but the controversial
addition that's truly gotten some heat
are the kidney and pinto beans so do you
think beans belong in Chile obviously
like I thought that beans were the key
ingredient in a chili beans is what
makes it a chili and not like a meat
stew I'm just rethinking everything I
know but also I feel like my idea of
chili is based on like the Pinnacle of
chilies which for me growing up was like
the Wendy's chili and that was a bean
chili but the thing about chili and
something that we do do not really
participate in is like sour cream and
cheese because it's the mixing of meat
and dairy so I don't do that in my chili
I never I wouldn't cuz that sounds
literally disgusting but like Ben
wouldn't oh you do oh hell yeah he
doesn't put cheese on his chili I don't
think so I can't chili without sour
cream is like french fries without
ketchup like sure I'll do it but it
could be so much better uh I mean you
know my take on this I actually I don't
love french fries and ketchup like I
think good french fries don't require
ketchup that's what my husband says too
and I just think he's wrong for that
like the best fren try in the world is
made even better with a smack mattering
of I don't have ketchup on my McDonald's
french fries cuz they're so good no
you're wrong for that that's like how
it's Sugarfish they don't give you soy
sauce they think their Sushi doesn't
need it but my mouth is just so
accustomed to like sushi and soy sauce
like Yeah The Sushi is great but where's
the sauce bro no I hear you but I
actually I agree with the Sugarfish
people like you're going to put out good
[__] then I'll respect it you know you
don't need to like mask it right with
crapola
MSG yeah I just I understand their
arguments I do but I just know how I
feel on my taste buds and like what I
require I also didn't know that beans
was considered like a polarizing subject
when it came to chili like I thought it
was so obvious that's like putting you
know meat in your chili like it's duh
yeah I didn't know that was one of the
things that were like optional I thought
you know obviously a tomato base meat
and beans were what you need and then
the other you get creative you get
creative some people put corn ew some
people put uh bell peppers I one of my
recipes calls for bell peppers and I do
it I like it when Ben makes chili if we
have Peppers he puts them in I like it
too but Zach doesn't like Peppers
so that's so funny I feel like of all
the vegetables like I can tolerate a a
pepper like they really taste like
nothing he's so anti- pepper it's crazy
really yeah we're talking like bell
pepper right all peppers and Cracked
Pepper he really doesn't go for I am
with him Cracked Pepper is the Devil's
Dust like there's quite literally no
reason pepper needs to exist when a meal
comes at a restaurant and you can just
tell it's covered in Pepper I'm out and
of course like red pepper flakes but I
don't do those either hate hate like if
I ever make stuffed peppers like he
won't engage and that's hurtful I love
stuffed peppers okay I love stuffed
peppers too but like I'm eating the
stuff not the peppers right but I feel
like for him he's so anti- pepper it's
like he is to Peppers as like Margot is
to cream cheese I understand like
stubborn stubborn about it that I don't
even know if he would eat what's in the
boat cuz he can't get over the vessel
itself oh well that's nutty because I'm
the pickiest [__] alive and like I'll
tell you a bell pepper tastes like
nothing I know and you know why I
actually weirdly have like a soft spot
in my heart for Bell Peppers even though
it's like not something you would think
I would eat why because when you cook
them in a pan like nothing smells better
than that like your house is immediately
like the most delicious place on the
planet you are you sure yeah I love the
smell well you should put some peppers
on the stove to chren your new house
100%
I'm so excited for your cooking Journey
I'll send you some I'll send you some
cookbooks from Amazon yeah I have one
cookbook we used it for uh Russ and like
I feel like it went so well you know who
you're going to
love who Joanna Half Baked Harvest yeah
know I saw those cookies in her book
when I was at your house like it's legit
it's legit that's those are the best
recipes and Joanna I love I love them
all aa's great too but AA food's like
weirdly healthy no and I need to get
like one of those like um SP cookbook
opener holders yeah it's like made of
lose site and it's like so Chic yeah no
I have one and when I got it they
actually accidentally sent two so I gave
one to Olivia cuz like that's what you
do but I know she doesn't use cookbooks
I don't think she uses it I'm going to
give it to you yeah no like the thing is
I have an island in my new apartment
which I've never had before and I think
that really changes actually like the
fun of your home cuz I was saying to Ben
like now my dining room my living room
and my kitchen are all the same
room you could be or Ben's cooking
you're on the couch you're together it
creates togetherness it creates
togetherness and like that's what I
think my home is missing like that's why
I'm always in my bed like I I don't want
to be in my bed so much like I want to
spend time in my living room if that
makes sense yeah I do so I'm re like I'm
so excited I don't like I can't think of
anything else I'm excited for you I'm
excited to stay there we can cook
together we can
Vlog oh that's the other thing like this
is just like a Content friendly home
there's so much natural light there's
like a a big kitchen like if I really
did want to like make a cooking Vlog I I
have the perfect place for a tripod
right now my kitchen is like straight
it's a galley kind of like a hallway and
that's not conducive for Content yeah so
it's good for business oh oh and I
didn't even mention this I have the
biggest
bathtub oh wow I didn't see I need to
watch the video again I watched it like
I fast forwarded it just to like see
because you needed an answer for me on
what I thought but now that I know that
that's like where I'm going to be
staying where we're going to be making
chilies I and me and Ben were actually
saying how we actually like the guest
bedroom better than what's considered
like the primary bedroom it's just like
a better like Vibe like there's so much
like light you have sick views like it's
just like a really good bedroom that's
kind of like I love my master bedroom at
home but my guest bedroom is really
great here too like just great fun
everyone who stays there loves it yes so
um I have a big tub that I can fit in
bath time Q&A are coming back I have not
taken a bath in my home in years and at
first it was because I was too fat right
and but then it was just like I want a
big tub like now I'm just not I'm not
interested yeah like I'm going to be in
my tub for hours like I need to get an
iPad for my tub yeah you need to get
like um what are those things that goes
across the tub I have one they're kind
of crappy though they like they don't no
and like it's annoying like yeah yeah
it's not right and it's annoying yeah so
anyways I'm Pro beans and chili but
sound off in the comments yeah but
people that's the thing and what I love
about chili is it's so personal I know
some people put peanut butter in theirs
I know people have cornbread with it I
know people have Cinnabons with it like
it's regional for sure but it's also
personal it's how you grow up and I do
feel like you can't mess up a chili and
whatever you want to put in your chili
like it's it's
customizable yeah but I do feel like
beans are the
Bedrock beans are the
Bedrock beans are the Bedrock beans
beans are the
Bedrock that nobody can deny except for
these people on Tik Tok but they'll find
fault with anything speaking of Tik Tok
um we made a Tik Tok account for the
toast it's called at the toast pod and
I'd appreciate any followers I really
would how are we doing on followers oh
you know I have Tik Tok on my iPad oh I
think I'm logged into the toast now we
have about 5,000 followers and it's not
enough I was logged out okay it's going
to take me a year to get back in but I
will we don't have enough followers so
have 5,000 5,000 okay if everyone who
listens to this podcast who has Tik Tok
how many people do you think who listen
to the podcast have Tik Tok I would say
40% oh wow I was going to say 60 okay
we'll meet in the middle at 50 50 goes
and follows will be respectable yeah we
need to be respectable you guys like
help us yeah come on don't let your
girls be embarrassed don't make me buy
followers cuz you know my ass well are
you ready for our fifth and final story
a little more food news a little more
food news Burger King drops a new french
fries and onion rings combo Oh Oh I
thought you meant they were overhauling
their french fries because I was about
to be upset I actually think they have
good fries they do have good fries so
you'll never have to be torn between
fries or onion rings again with Burger
King's latest menu item havies it's
called starting October 12th customers
can order havies a side or order of half
French fries half onion rings the ideal
combo for indecisive guests the new item
is available Alla cart or as part of a
small medium or large valy meal no to no
one surpris like I don't really [__]
with onion rings to no one's surprise so
this is cool for other people I never
struggle be with like damn should I get
the fries of the onion rings like it's
always fries for me but I imagine there
are people who deal with that um I kind
of dealt with it when I was on our
mukbang and I forget where we were but
they had tater tots I'm like oh tater
tots are fries tater tots are fries so
should we do a half and half like I love
that I love that it's really really
thoughtful for them making decisions is
is really hard like all different types
so Burger King doing their part to
alleviate that stress like we have to be
grateful yeah especially like there are
big decisions that need to be made every
day like which apartment are we going to
get right and so to take out some of
these smaller decisions just makes life
more
beautiful to take out some of these
smaller decisions just makes life more
beautiful I also did not know that
Burger King had onion rings I've never
had them I feel like if you had pressed
me and asked I would have said yeah like
I don't know it's actually crazy that
like more fast food joints don't have
onion rings it's not crazy actually cuz
when I want think of burger I think of
fries I don't need onion RS it's not
crazy but where onion rings are like so
Random where do you eat onion rings like
a diner yeah or I guess a burger joint
that would have like you know good onion
rings cuz I feel like onion rings are
really hard to get right like they go
they turn to crap so quickly they have
to be eaten hot they have to be prepared
well nothing better than like a Sho
string onion ring though you wouldn't
know but yeah I know what you're talking
about they kind of like PJ Clark's yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah go to PJ Clark's get
the onion rings and the chili PJ Clarks
has great chili and the mashed potatoes
I I forgot who I was just having this
conversation with oh when I was at to
dinner with Ben and our friends we were
eating at polar bar so it was like very
um sides oriented because it's a kind of
like a Stak housy Vibes so like we had
mashed potatoes and we were talking
about like the best sides on the planet
and it's like ival truth that the best
mac and cheese on the planet is from
Boston Market yes for
sure yeah how do we get here I don't
know I was checking about PJ Clark's oh
they're mashed potatoes oh my God so
good but also the mashed potatoes I was
eating that night oh that's how I got
there the Mas potatoes that I was eating
that night that started that
conversation were excellent from Polar
bar I I love a [__] mashed potato
that looks like a soup I like a chunky
and I like skin
in that's why I don't really [__] with
Wendy's french fries they're skin on
yeah it's like they're trying to prove
like it's fast food but they're real
potatoes we don't care no they're not
right like oh you painted on some skin
like you think you're fooling
us well for everyone who's was torn
between onion rings and Fries worry no
more and I I like this trend I just want
to say I like the idea of havies like if
we did fries and
tots what else fries and cheese fries
they have those uh chicken sticks yeah
yeah yeah oh um I think some some have
mozzarella sticks yeah yeah no just
being able to like a combo like a combo
variety we love variety guess we'll have
to do another mukbang tury l oh [__]
you know I'm down with my car yeah but
we have to really do one down here cuz
one it would be like so easy the one in
New York was genuinely one of the worst
afternoons of my life it was seriously
no like I can't even I don't even want
to hear you complain because you were 9
months pregnant and you had got to sit
in the car the whole time I had to run
in and pick up all over our food no I
was so not okay it was horrible but we
did discover Sonic which was like I'm
grateful for no like it's nice that you
want to paint it with a pretty picture
but it was horrible like I'm not like
I'm not like I look back on it like so
and I shiver unfly and I quake
it was oh my I can't remember when we
were sitting on the outer rail for like
40 minutes oh my God that traffic yeah
cuz we took the [__] outer rail
yeah I remember it was frightening you
guys this is the last you're going to
hear from us until Jackie's book comes
out so I the next time you guys hear
from me on this forum I'm going to be a
published author a that's
crazy so exciting so make sure to get
your copies reminder that Monday There's
no show Tuesday we are back Jax is going
to be in New York it's Pub day OG recipe
all week it's OG recipe all week but I
had booked a guest co-host before I knew
that Jackie was coming to New York and I
didn't want to move him it's just it's
someone who's been on the toast who
everybody loves so we decided to just
keep him on and have the toast be the
three of us because what if he just
joined us that would be fun so that's
one day next week next week is going to
be really fun so Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday we got Jackson Studio so
much content next week I'm also doing
Talk Shop live again on Wednesday at 6
o'clock so we're just going to be having
fun in the studio camper and counselors
selling books talking smack Thursday
we've got great
Trifecta yep Friday is always a party
it's always a party and then Saturday
I'm going to be meeting you guys at
books and greetings 11:00 a.m. Northvale
New Jersey you have to get a ticket in
order to come to the event so the link
is in my Instagram I'm going to keep
posting it on my store stories you have
to get a ticket your ticket buys you a
book as signed B and entry and entry so
that's what you're paying for when you
buy the ticket you are buying a signed
book and you get to meet your girl and
once upon Farm Tings fabulous thank you
guys so much for listening to the toast
the millenni morning show where we the
[Music]
fly talented we are hope you guys have a
great weekend enjoy the three weekend if
you have it and we love you dearly bye
love you bye